what most amazing my Purple Rain is that
so many people have tried to do the
magic of the artists at the exact right
point in his career and the exact right
movie and the exam and the timing of the
soundtrack was the reach of the film
it's really a miraculous situation that
you guys pull it off so what was the
genesis of that yeah I'd like to take
credit but first of all let me say that
my partner Joe Ruffalo's in New York yes
Oh Joe Ruffalo stand up for a second Joe
and Steve for anole whose only job the
reason he became a partner in Joe and my
company was that Prince demanded that I
moved to Minneapolis with my family and
I was already you know I'm pretty
successful manager at the time so Steve
had to spend 24 hours a day but anyway I
sent Steve was on tour with Prince
Prince wasn't big we'd done a good job
he was a couple of million records and
he could sell a thousand seats mm maybe
2500 I send for anole a new contract for
him to sign because the first five-year
contracts going to be up in about six
months we've done I think a magnificent
job so I'm sure he'll sign it Barnaul he
calls and he tells Joe and I you're not
gonna believe this but he won't sign it
unless you get him a major motion
picture and you can't get some drug
dealer to finance it you got to get a
major studio and it and he wants a name
above the title I mean I couldn't even
boot I knew about the films but I
couldn't believe that he was knowing
prints you have to do pretty much if he
starts driving it you want to go so I
went to our lawyer and skip Brittenham
and he tell it gave me William Blinn and
we got a screenplay it's kind of TV you
know he had done Brian saw which was a
excellent TV movie but and Prince just
wanted to start you know so I'm trying
to find it director and I'll go
quickly every director in town passed
every studio passed after all there was
unknown everybody and and we're gonna
make a major motion picture so to make a
long story short I go my last try is for
Jamie Foley and I see this movie i
screen this movie reckless it hadn't
come out yet I'm all by myself in the
screening room the movie ends I stand up
and this kid comes down the aisle and
says what did you think and I said I was
okay
I liked the editing and he says oh I did
that that was Albert and he and he says
and so I said I'm trying to and I tell
him my story he said well you ought to
see my student film there was a film
called jazz and it was magnificent but
the fact is that's how it started and
I'm gonna cut right to the chase I go to
Albert I know I have to start the movie
your prince is gonna go crazy and you
know when his creative juices were going
he had to start so to make a long story
short I go to a arts deli I think do
parse excuse me we've been arguing about
where this happened ha ha ha couple but
anyway so I offer him the movie in
$75,000 which was the DTA and he passed
I said you haven't got a pot to piss in
excuse my French
how could you pass he said well it's to
square I said well I understand that way
well let let what did you say for real
well I passed I passed but it wasn't it
the restaurant I had passed a day before
I passed because I read it and I didn't
think it was large enough it was a small
film and I just felt that it could be
much larger and so I said to him I'm
going to pass he immediately got very
angry there's a lot of bad language
and he said everybody in town is passing
and now you you're on a d-list you don't
exist
you're just an editor and Bob yes Bob
did that to you I can't believe it but
you're just an editor and so why should
I even bother speaking to you and I said
I said I went to film school I know
nothing but you're in the music business
and you know less than I do
oh whoa by the way as if you should all
know that he's a writer and this is
really sounds good but this is not at
that point how familiar were you with
Prince and his music okay interestingly
enough nine months earlier I was in my
apartment in Silver Lake
yeah and the song 1999 came on and I
immediately got up from that desk and I
realized at that moment that this is an
anthem and that basically I could make a
movie with that song
so it was really interesting to me that
months later I'm editing wreckless I
meet Bob I pass on an offer and I just
said and it was really based on the fact
that I heard in 1999 and I said this
could be a much bigger amount and so we
met at DU pars and he explained to me he
explained to me what had happened and
why this had not gotten started and I
said basically what he needs to do is
send a writer-director to Minneapolis
sit with Prince in the entire
organization and really try to
understand what was going on there and
then once that was done right from the
heart and I said that's the only way
this can even have a chance he liked a
deal and he I said all you have to do is
send me let me meet him tomorrow night
and if it works out great and if it
doesn't you're on a plane ticket and a
motel room and he said that's a deal I
could live that far it was true that's
so the next day I was literally picked
up and from the studio I was working at
and I was brought to Minneapolis now the
funny thing is at the time Bob rarely
spoke to Steve who he just explained was
with Prince 24/7 so I get off the plane
the first thing Steve does is come up to
me and says you know that story you
pitched Bob forget it we're doing the
reg original script I don't want to hear
about this story I don't know that's
that's the script we're doing Bob
doesn't know what he's doing and that's
all there is to it Wow because I had
been in film school I understood because
we were taught in film school that there
will be people like this in the film
business
hahahaha no Albert you're writing a
movie here nope it's true
I can't believe Stevie said they did all
right better then because that evening I
met Prince yes and the fascinating thing
about being in the hotel Steve said
you're gonna meet Prince tonight he's
gonna come out of the elevator at 12:00
midnight and you'll meet him there
we're gonna go to a restaurant have a
meal and you're gonna talk to him about
why you love the script as it is mm-hmm
and I said okay and I wanted to separate
myself from him and chick who was
princes bodyguards about six five and
weighed 250 pounds and I said okay and I
walked away from them and I was standing
on the side of the room the lobby and
Prince came out on my right-hand side
out of the elevator and walked all the
way across the lobby to see Steve and
chick because he didn't know was it
midnight it was midnight
it was 12:01 and in that walk over I
realized pretty much the rest of the
story based on just I saw a vulnerable
kid who was a little shy and just
insulated and I said okay and we went to
the restaurant and in spite of the fact
that prince said okay what do you think
about the script that's written when can
we start and I said I'm not here to
discuss the script there's a new story
here it is and basically within 10
minutes he said to me okay how is it
that in 10 minutes you tell me my life
story and I said if you're willing to
take the hit because I want the father
to hit you pretty hard in the front of
the film if you're willing to do that we
can make a great movie and he said why
is that so important to you and I said
because there isn't a person on the
planet who doesn't want to take a hit at
a rock star
and he understood that and said let's do
it fantastic fantastic